he is the I guess that when we call them
the new top draft expert at the NFL
Network the lead the senior draft expert
I mean DJ how do you want to be referred
to Daniel Jeremiah what do you think
I've been all this media I've been doing
and I'll run up to the event rich I've
been introduced I think my business card
officially says the new Mayock the new
I've been called yeah my kids now hey
the dinner's ready
our everything you may our new Mayock
hashtag new Mayock antennas a new Mayock
in town people and his name is Daniel
Jeremiah good to good to chat with you
brother right off the bat we know you're
not Mayock because you didn't go to ours
in your first and I found that work I'm
glad you brought this up yeah because
there is some stats involved there with
the length now let's keep in mind a
couple different things sir okay keep in
mind with the age no bathroom breaks
okay factored in no bathroom breaks
number one number two there's no there's
no you know I have my notebook where I
start with the process but I put
everything into this thing called a
computer so I can access the information
a little quicker mm-hmm so I think if
you factor all these things then that
baby my conference call length would
have been extended a little bit when you
do the conversion well I mean to use a
little bit more of the phraseology than
from your world the eye and the sky does
not lie and it was an hour and 55
minutes TJ I was like how do you not
just at that point just going extra five
minutes just to clock in at two hours
how does it look Andrew Howard show man
I'm just dropping name of an NFL Network
member of the NFL Network PR staff DJ
let's get into it Kyler Mario over over
Dwayne Haskins what why do you have that
on your top 50 going into the combine
pure yeah when I started out with the
process I had two real concerns with
Kyle Emery and they weren't based off of
what I saw in the field it was number
one first and foremost are you committed
to football because there you cannot you
cannot play two sports of that position
I don't think you can flirt with another
sport just use one of Dion's
phrases there
I just wouldn't work so that was a
concern well he checked that box by
eliminating baseball then you go to the
second concern for me was durability you
know not the height it was more to me
about the bulk I had heard from some
people that had went through a coma
you know he's probably gonna weigh 185
pounds 183 pounds somewhere in that
range
I've managed I don't know if you'd hold
up at that position at that weight so
now I find out and I think Peter King
reported the other day that he was up to
what 206 pounds or something so I don't
know if he played it 200 if you played
it 195 or whatever but the fact that
he's over 200 pounds helps helps with
some of that because he does do a good
job for a smaller quarterback much like
Russell Wilson of protecting himself
he'll slide he gets out of balance he'll
turn his shoulder when he's got heavy
pressure so when you're when you're
smaller like that your whole life
you kind of know how to how to protect
yourself a little bit so let's talk sit
then yep giant sitting there six overall
when we're there on the first Thursday
night of the draft in Tennessee and have
a choice between the two guys you would
counsel the Giants to take Kyle Amari
over Dwayne Haskins
I have Kyler Murray over Haskins so if I
was running a team I would I was going
that direction now if you say
forecasting what do I think they would
do I would say Dewayne Haskins fits the
mold obviously with more of what they've
had their traditionally with the Giants
so it's kind of two different two
different questions there the only thing
I would caution is it last year can you
find a more polar opposite quarterback
from Lamar Jackson than Joe Flacco so
that was a total shift in philosophy
there for the Ravens who knows maybe the
Giants shocked us and do the same thing
so what would be your concern on on
Murray is it truly is height I mean is
there anything about the measurement
tomorrow that would concern you when he
finally steps as we all assume he will
next to a tape measure yeah I've you
know I come back to the when Russell
came out and I remember what my grade
was on Russell Wilson before he met he
measured at the Senior Bowl
and I had a mid top of the second round
type grade and after the after Senior
Bowl I I can't tell you the number of
times I had people tell me in a hundred
years and NFL ever been anybody like
this so you're gonna say this is the one
it's gonna really make it happen it's
gonna you know and I allow that to kind
of scare me off my grade a little bit I
dropped him around I dropped the third
round range we were in Philadelphia
winded up not getting him there and then
I kind of Val from that day four I'm
just gonna trust my eyes man
and when I watched Tyler Murray there
was some moments in the first half of
the Alabama game where I thought he
looked small I hope he can see and and
this is an issue and then he pulled
himself out of it he adjust to it and it
showed that he could function in that
type of environment so everything else I
saw drive the football touch throws work
through progressions I saw all of it and
then you add on top of that just such a
dynamic weapon with his legs that I'm
not going to get scared off the 5/9
thing well I mean in terms of Russell
Wilson he had meat hooks like he was six
foot five though I mean so is that
something
is that more pertinent than hand-sized
and how tall colors gonna be when we
find out tomorrow
yeah I mean somebody who's a longtime
paranoid scout I'm already I'm already
letting myself to answer the questions
if his hands come in at eight and six
you know eight and three quarters or
eight and seven eighths but again when I
watched these when I watched the tape I
never saw it as an issue so I'm in I'm
in the boat rich so you know we'll only
what these measurements come in damn
straight you are you got him above two
Haskins on your top fifty and I don't
know anybody else who does I mean last
one for you on this before we move on
Daniel Jeremiah are you hearing that he
might not throw Saturday what are you
hearing they're at Indianapolis about
Morris I know I'm crossing fingers and
toes that he'll do everything for our
sake but have not heard anything yet so
why wouldn't he throw I mean it's it's
it's every year we have this about a top
prospect we know Darnell didn't throw if
I'm not mistaken luck did not throw
obviously that didn't have anything to
do with their draft positioning events
or their readiness for the NFL I mean
what what what would that indicate to
you yay or nay Daniel well you know I
don't think there's anything that as you
mentioned a couple of players there's
nothing that really correlates between
whether you throw here and what kind of
player you're going to be so it's it's
you know it's just kind of a personal
decision of whether you want to or not
the only reason I would think he
wouldn't throw is not knowing the
particulars of the decision-making
process to not do baseball and to
connect solely to football so in other
words when the season ended most of
these guys immediately went to training
facilities had started throwing and
working out getting ready to go for this
event now when did that process start
for him obviously you know first hand
haven't talked to him at the Super Bowl
at that point in time nothing was was
decided so when did he begin the
training process would probably answer
whatever might we're gonna see him
alright and then I lied last one for you
on this Honda insider porteño Jeremiah
you do you're your pod to move the
sticks pod with Bucky Brooks who if I'm
not mistaken tweeted out that he likes
Haskins more than anybody in last year's
quarterback class do you agree with that
no I love Bucky and we'll have a fun
discussion about that on the podcast
today but I I don't I'd have him behind
Donald Rosen Mayfield and and Josh Allen
for me he would be behind those guys
again it's he's a good player I have him
as the eighteenth player in this draft I
thought last year's group was really
really good so I assume you heard DJ
Steve calm say that that rosin is right
now for sure their quarterback
[Music]
we're wondering what the inflection is
you know I got to reach out to comm I'm
gonna text him in the commercial break
see if he'll come on or just tell me
which which word did you actually accent
well there pause right now sounds better
that he's our quarterback pause right
now it's very very the comma placement
is crucial I would agree with you but
any chance you think that Murray is
taking number one overall cuz we could
connect dots as we all know with
Kingsbury and Murray number one overall
and etc etc look it's it's still being
floated around you know people that
don't that
don't know but are here with other teams
you know you talk about it continue to
say hey I wouldn't rule it out you know
based off what I'm just telling you I
wouldn't rule it out so there's nothing
it's not steeped in any fact but until
they turn in the card at number one and
maybe this will draw some more intrigue
to our coverage but until they turn the
card in I don't think we can completely
rule that thing out somebody brought
this up to me the other day how about
this for a plan for the Cardinals in the
offseason okay
they take Tyler Murray at one right you
trade rosin for a one somewhere else in
this draft who to whatever team right so
you get you come away with Kyler Murray
another really good player and then you
have it that pick at the top of the
second round which you trade for Antonio
Brown maybe you have to add a little
sugar to something else and then you
lineup next year with Tyler Murray David
Johnson Antonio Brown Cristian Kirk
Larry Fitzgerald and you go run that
that AIRAID offense but kind of fun
right sold I like it well Brock when you
you as long as that rosin pick goes to
the Patriots yes I mean what's your
evaluation I like Rosen you went and
hired you went and hired Kliff Kingsbury
so what's more out of the box
I mean you hired a coach who just got
fired at Texas Tech to be your NFL head
coach you know punting on a quarterback
after one year to bring in his guy that
would not be the craziest thing you've
done in the offseason
Kirk Brown Fitzgerald David Johnson
Carla Murray let's roll Patrick Peterson
and then it's in the secondary Chandler
Jones I would agree with that you got to
throw that out there many many times
during our broadcast over the next we
need some more airtime also to DJ Daniel
Jeremiah here in the Honda inside a
report before we we have a bunch of time
together on the NFL Network live over
the next few days but Nick Bose is out
there man I mean right you could still
you could still have Rosen at the
controls of everything that you just
said but add Bosa to Chandler Jones and
go hunt I mean that guy how special is
Nick Bose
compared to other pass rushers that have
come out maybe even miles garret number
one overall his brother who went top
five where does boast a rank on all of
that he's really good man in terms of my
you know recent guys that went way up
there that I had big grades on from
behind Garrett and clowny were just two
physical freaks but I have a higher
grade on him than Bradley Chubb and we
saw Bradley Chubb go double digits last
year as a rookie he is he is a really
really good player so you know I see his
brother each and every week there in the
fall and you see a lot right where he's
there I know you're happy he's he's
moving on from Ohio State he's healthy
rich if he's healthy for me I just turn
in the cards I feel great about it
number one I've given up a long time ago
about being happy that Bose is legal out
of state because there's always another
one coming you know it's like a
turnstile for crying out loud with the
turnstile you know but give me somebody
you're excited to see that we're not
talking about coming into the app people
always ask what's your favorite part of
the combine it's pretty simple man let's
watch fast guys run fast and when you
look at the receiver position
another one from Ohio State Parris
Campbell was gonna fly and then there's
a kid Nicole Hartman from Georgia who
when you watch him on the tape receipt
just he just jumps off the screen he's
so explosive so guys like that watching
them you get a chance to run now rashon
Gary your guy everything I hear buckle
up he's gonna he's gonna put on a show
he's gonna be 280 and he's gonna run
some ridiculous 40 time and blow out all
the other testings so it's fun man I
know some people ask the underwear
Olympics come on we get to watch these
guys run around catch the football throw
the football run and jump it's the best
I know it's exciting and what you have
and your top five prospects you have
number five TJ Hawkinson had tied in
from Iowa worked how do you have a tight
end so high on your list
he's double-oh-seven I mean he's a he's
a trained killer he is so fun to watch I
watched him the day after seeing
Brockman's guy Gronk
beat the chargers in the postseason on
the flight down to Tampa after that game
they go to the east-west game I watched
Hawkinson and I'm just seeing you know
gerak dominated game in the run game and
this kid is just destroying people in
the running he is so physical and then
he's he's more than more than enough
athletically catches everything run
clean Ralph's he's a he's a really good
player he's not croc drunk is a unicorn
there's only one of him but I've seen
how an inline tight end that can really
really block what an asset he can be and
with all these teams with young
quarterbacks who helps them the most in
this draft to me it's it's Hawkinson all
right and you understand DJ what your
most important job of the week is
correct
Oh am i doing the clock I don't know I
know
Fiat was gonna come out of the bullpen I
don't know it watch I don't think Mayock
is going to Chi I mean it would be
wonderful if he did I just don't see him
looking at Gruden and saying hey late
Sunday when I'm running just I'll be
there in an hour
you know I'm gonna miss you know I'm
gonna miss those three interviews
tonight of those guys we were thinking
about what those personal picks but I'll
be in there after 40 so you will just
make sure you've got the the the trigger
finger that's a little bit more shall we
say understanding then Mike okay what
was the last 40 you timed actually the
last 40 I timed would have been at a pro
day and gosh I'd have to go back and
look at her it's 2012 seven years I've
had seven years off rusty I really do
look forward to hanging with you in the
booth and and bringing the combine to
folks on the NFL Network thanks for
calling in Paul C an indie right back a
chat moved the sticks gotta follow me
he's a must follow the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience